Well, it's about that time. Jai and DOC
are moving to the US. They've been doing
shows with some of the most epic
smackdowns ever for years now, but
you've never seen their faces because
it's just not safe for them in the UK
and DOC is an ex-Muslim. So, they're
packing up their bags and moving to the
US where things aren't nearly as
dangerous and where they can do things
that so many of us take for granted like
show our faces.
Here in a week or two, Jai and DOC face
reveal. And then they can know what it's
like to have the freedom that's being
destroyed in the UK.
They've leased a home, so they've got a
place to live when they get here. My son
went and picked up the keys today.
They've got jobs when they get here.
They'll be working for me, but working
for me means spending half your time
working on stuff with me and the other
half of your time building up your own
channel and producing your own content.
So, they're going to be cranking out a
lot of material. We're going to have
live call-in shows. We're going to make
lots of regular videos. We're going to
invade other platforms. Not like the old
Zoot invaded Muhammad, but you get the
picture. We're going to invade TikTok to
teach these young bucks some apologetics
and manners.
But here's where you can help now.
It's way too expensive to have their
stuff moved across the ocean, so they're
giving all their stuff away before they
leave. All they're bringing from the UK
to the US is their clothes and suitcases
and their laptop.
Which sucks by the way. They need a new
one that doesn't crash every time they
work with a big video file. So, they
have a place to live, they have jobs,
but they have no furniture, no car, no
dishes, no bedding, no equipment for
recording, and so on.
I asked Jai to send me a picture of what
they'd like their personal studio space
to look like. Here's what they came up
with for the Jai and DOC show.
But they've got a lot of expenses. They
have all their legal expenses they've
had to cover already just to get here.
Plane tickets, a little studio space for
making videos, furniture, a car, and
since this is apparently the year of
keyboard jihadis doxxing everyone,
they'll need some security cameras and
such. Anyway, I'm going to make sure
they have everything they need one way
or another, but if you'd like to chip in
to help them move and get set up here in
the US. If you'd like to give them a
warm welcome to the US, click the link
in the description and chip in to the
GiveSendGo we set up for them. If we can
get their little studio costs covered,
Thaddeus and I might try to set it all
up before they get here, so it's ready
to go for them.
Help out if you can, and it's going to
be a fun year.
Just not for you, Dawah guys.
You die on that.
It is not fun anymore. [music] You die
on that.
You die on that.
It is not fun anymore. [music] This is a
powerful religion. There's a reason to
it. Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?